let's jump into this first story you
know it's it's a tough call like how how
how in the weeds is this daily caller
sues chicago mayor for limiting
interviews to people of color basically
anti-white racism that's what tulsi
gabbard said one of the only politicians
with the guts to actually
call out this fringe insanity the hill
reports
the daily caller news foundation and one
of its reporters is suing chicago mayor
lori lightfoot
the lawsuit filed in the u.s district
court for the northern district of
illinois accuses lightfoot
of ignoring an interview request from
thomas kadenachi
a reporter for the publication because
he is not a journalist of color
the suit filed by conservative
government watchdog group judicial watch
claims lightfoot violated
kedonachi's first amendment and equal
protection rights
the mayor's office has not yet filed a
legal response to the suit according to
a federal court electronic records
database
quote the city has not had the
opportunity to review the complaint
and has not yet been served the chicago
department of law said when asked about
the suit
hiranachi referred questions about the
suit to judicial watch
defendant is aware that plaintiff
kedonachi is not a journalist of color
and defendant has denied plaintiff's
interview request pursuant to her
announcement
that she will only grant interview
requests from journalists of color the
suit states
the lawsuit asks the court to force
lightfoot to give
kadanachi an interview and also pay the
plaintiff's attorney's fees and
litigation costs
i think it's a good thing i think this
is the kind of thing that people need to
be doing more of
uh so far it seems like now outside of
the daily caller james o'keefe and
veritas are the only ones who are really
filing these lawsuits
challenging the insanity but they're too
often getting away with this stuff
now i also would like to point out the
absurdity of like if he wins what he
gets to interview lori lightfoot
so she'll just be like screw you i guess
she'll pay for it why like why didn't
she just say no i don't want to enter i
don't want to talk to that guy why did
she have to make it about race in the
first place because she's racist yeah
exactly
why did she keep it to herself she tried
to make this whole pr move where she was
like i will only be interviewing
i don't even think it's just poc i think
it's she said specifically
black and brown or like black and latinx
or whatever i don't think she's
including asia
sorry tim we we won't be interviewing
lori life but she was trying to make it
into this look how progressive thing i
am so that's why she didn't just say no
it's because it was part of a
she was trying to score awoke points and
now she's being sued so
you get what you deserve but this is
this this kind of stuff we're seeing in
government is
is just you know i want to talk about
this because we recently saw that other
lawsuit where the guy
he sued biden because biden's doing this
relief program for kovid but not to
white people right
and then there's another program where
farmers can get like a debt repayment
but
not to white people so you know this is
it seems to me they found a way to enact
their
critical race theory agenda without
going through the normal channels
because the normal channels would block
them
if they i mean they're still doing it if
they said we want to take all of the
wealth from white people and give it to
non-white people and create a communist
utopia and race at the system
it's not gonna fly but if they say oh
you know we're gonna we're gonna help
everyone get their business up and
running
but we're only giving money to you know
certain races then they're doing some
kind of
it's insane ideological manipulation of
the system
for some kind of social outcome well i
mean it and it's systemic racism i
support anyone who's suing
on the grounds that the government is
telling you you aren't eligible for a
certain benefit or
whatever specifically because of your
race and this is exactly what
the left likes to talk about all the
time right systemically racist policies
they talk about things like redlining
and jim crow which yes we're racist but
the answer to balance it out is not you
know just throw in a little bit of
anti-white racism to counteract the
anti-black racism and so then it's
everything's okay it's like no
that's not the answer communism it's
it's it's increasingly i mean
you know a lot of people have mentioned
like cultural marxism and stuff but
i mean you look at what's going on with
the state department they're putting
putting up these flags the embassies or
whatever
blm flags blm flags pride flags i'm like
those flags don't represent the country
it is a cult ideology is is absolutely
ingrained
in our government right now and uh i
don't know how you
you you get that out that's that's an
ideological stink
lawsuits is good filing a suit i don't
think you know in the end him getting an
interview early change anything
but pushing back against the racism is
important well and i think
half of the battle is really just
awareness because for the longest time i
would say at least the past four or five
years this kind of stuff has been
brewing and most people didn't know
about it right the normies the everyday
people who
aren't really politically engaged and if
we look at what's happening with all of
these different states banning crt in
schools
lydia and i were talking about this
earlier the only reason why that's
happening
now versus a couple years ago when it
started is because now
parents actually know about it because
they were doing zoom classes from home
with their kids and they were actually
looking over the material maybe for the
first time
so it's like with this lori lightfoot
thing the lawsuit is important because
at least now the people in chicago will
know like hang on my mayor thinks this
is a good idea like well i don't i don't
think anyone's gonna
anyone's gonna care a whole lot i just
think this could set set precedent
there's some pushback but for the
schools
i mean think about what that means for
years for for a generation parents
never paid attention whether you don't
ask your kid what did you learn in
school today yeah
i remember when i came back from school
when i was little kids like what did you
learn i was like i learned about
when i was a little kid my mom she was
she was very progressive for this
generation
i come back from school and she asked me
what i learned and i mentioned something
about christopher columbus you know 1492
sailing the ocean blue
you discovered america my mom was like
there were already people here
and i was like yeah it's like yeah the
native americans i was like yeah she's
like so they discovered america and i
was like oh
did you tell me about leif erickson yep
the viking that's right that always
so it's so it's like i never understood
why schools were always lying but
here's here's i guess i'm lucky i have a
parent who asks me what was going on in
school
and then she can give me better
information
today parents don't care they're not
raising their kids and it's insidious
like that it slid in to be honest i
don't know because i haven't been to
school in a while but
i would imagine that it's it's it's slid
into like it's not what they're teaching
it's just part of like
the the base of what's being taught you
know like they'll put it in the book
in the i don't know i haven't been to
school in a while but i imagine that
it's not like the overt
lesson every time it's just no no it's
worse than that
so i saw this one uh this one math
problem
so remember you used to get the like you
know train leaves
new york traveling at 65 miles an hour
another train leaves travel yeah
whatever so i saw one where it was like
you know jamal is a black man who gets
stopped by police 17 times in one week
and rick is a white man who gets stopped
by seven times what percentage of the
police stops were
yeah yeah no no seriously that's the
kind of stuff so it's part of the
ideology it's to have it be every facet
of their eye
of their understanding of the world i i
think
i'm hoping kids reject this kind of
stuff you know
when i was a little kid i rebelled kids
rebel and i hope hopefully the
institutionalization of
of the cult actually makes younger
people reject it
but imagine how creepy it's going to be
when look man
somebody somebody posted on uh on a
reddit it was like
a meme where it's like a kid i'm 10
years old and you're like so what it's
like i was born in 2011 and you're like
gross oh man wow yeah like you're
talking to someone who was born in 2014
and people are like what year
is it wow time flies yeah so in 20 years
from today
you're going to have people in congress
who are raised on all of this stuff
ingrained in their minds and their
worldview will be
absolute racism well i mean that's why
it's important i think that they're
actually doing something to address it
banning it and i
i was just seeing there was this little
twitter skirmish between you know
michael malus who i'm a huge fan of and
i think kathy young
um there are people arguing that you you
don't really support free speech if you
want to ban crt from schools but it's
like was that kathy young saying that i
think she was on the side of the person
who didn't want it to be banned
right who was saying like well the
writer just sjws too because they're
trying to ban this
isn't it funny she always does that yeah
i thought so a little bit i've
i've interviewed her before and it was
about something that i was on her side
of but i don't see how you can
compare not wanting to fund what is
obviously an ideological
like bent for young children with
trying to cancel people or being an sjw
when they used to complain about
and they still do especially if you go
on reddit religion in schools right it's
like yes get the ideology out of the
education
now it's the left putting an ideology
into education and
we're still saying no you shouldn't do
that but these people are acting like
that's acceptable that should be done
right and i don't think they see the
difference it's like no one like no one
on the right now in mainstream is
arguing that there should be
a you know christian funded education
mandatory in all schools
because i think we've you know america
has accepted that they don't want to do
that but when it comes to crt and the
less ideology
for some reason well that should fall
under free speech it's like i know like
you were saying if we're getting
ideology out it should be all ideologies
someone needs to start the church of
critical theory that way it's oh it's a
religion now like someone filed the
paperwork and now you can't have it in
schools yeah
they don't even bother with trying to
get a ban but a bunch of states are
banning it so i guess
it's a good thing um i don't know i feel
a bit nihilistic on it a bit pessimistic
like oh here we go here we go again it's
just going to keep happening i felt last
night
if you get to the kids you brainwash the
kids that you can
and then you don't even see the results
for 20 years or 15 years that's the
problem we don't realize the damage
we're doing
no no they they do well yeah they like
it yeah they don't think of it as damage
yeah they think of it as victory winning
isn't it amazing remember when that
republican lady was like
you know she i'm not going to quote her
she said something about
that guy from you know germany and how
she she claimed that him going after the
kids was a good tactic but she said in a
very very different way i won't repeat
yeah she said in a very crude way and
like all of a sudden the media erupted
like
how dare you say that about that man
it's like yeah you shouldn't you
shouldn't but
she was talking about how the nazis went
after kids
yeah and indoctrinated kids hitler youth
right and now
it's it's really funny because uh i said
it yesterday i'll say it again
when people always ask like how did it
get to the point where people were
standing in the streets doing the nazi
salute and i'm like the people are
marching around doing the red salute
right now like you don't even need to
ask the question
just look around you it's happening and
you know what people always think it
can't happen here
and then it does happen here it can
happen anywhere but it's not going to be
overnight
i don't know about that i used to think
you know slippery slope takes time it's
not going to be overnight look at what
happened with covid
look at how quickly it became the norm
to actually call
the police on your neighbors for having
people over that took a year like less
than a year
my favorite thing was like how quickly
the police started enforcing things that
weren't the law
it's like it's not there's no law saying
you have to you have to stay in your
house
and they're like well the governor said
so i'm like i'm sorry do you follow the
constitution in the law or just like
what the governor tells you to do
right yeah and all of these cops were
just like with smiles on their faces you
know beating and arresting people
there's a video it's really amazing man
reddit is awesome you ever gonna read it
i can't stand it i know that's why it's
awesome it is it's like it's like
it's looking into like the mirror
dimension it's like this parallel
paranoid reality
there was a video where it's a woman
having a breakdown over masks and she's
just screaming like i am done with this
i am done being bullied
the cdc data says and the cop grabs her
and arrests her
and the people are cheering calling her
karen and i'm like
she was citing cdc data and the cop
arrested her
dude the the younger generation that's
on these platforms
whether it's sock puppets manipulating
them it is becoming
1984 ultra cult authoritarian
it's creepy it is creepy and i even with
the mass thing
we were talking about this earlier i
mentioned online i see people in cities
walking around by themselves wearing
masks and they're not it's not like
there's anyone near them and i asked why
on social media people are doing that
and i had all these people saying well
it's to express my concern for others
because i care
so a i got a lot of people saying it's
to express something meaning that it is
a virtue signal it's a social signal
that you're showing that you care
you saw david hogg right no he tweeted
he didn't want people to think he was a
conservative oh my goodness so he's
wearing a mess because of that yeah
i mean it's like it's a social signaler
now so it's either you're doing this
just for
virtue points or you're we've been so
hyped into this fear this hysteria by
the media that people actually think
it's this deadly
that even if you're not sick the other
person isn't sick you're outside you're
not near each other you could still
spread it what thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel
youtube.com tim cast irl monday through
friday at 8pm where you can leave
comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else
go to timcast.com become a member and we
even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you